could you go on there and do like a bit
yeah is yeah I think that I doubt it
though
yeah I [ __ ] uh no oh yeah you know
what I mean like a little like a desk
piece ah damn you work in an outfit to
boo me and be like something fun uh yeah
that's the thing I don't think it would
be that fun yeah I think it would be fun
right personally yeah I think cuz I
walked past last week I walked past the
[ __ ] the line people sleep outside I
always look at those people I go wasn't
wrong with you so well see these guys so
much to do I walk past them that night
and like they all you know it's all
these like weirdos with like a Saturday
Night Live snow hat like in a sleeping
bag looking up from the street and I
walked by and they were like no they
recognize you they old of course me
look-ins knitted SNL scarves and [ __ ] it
was a geezer sick people going to show
like that and with all due respect
everyone works there because there's
there's one or two people on there that
are funny I always look at the show like
that and I go how does it have fans that
are like the the fervor of the fandom I
get watching it I get being like hey
this is on its sketch comedy and I think
a lot of the fans of that show are
casual fans like this is the thing
that's on Saturday night and listen it's
a his store it's an important show in in
a throughout history and it's had some
really amazingly funny stuff happen but
like in its current incarnation it's
interesting that there are people
sleeping on the street yeah dude I'm
amazed that people are sleeping on the
street to see anything
yeah yeah I mean the one thing that
would make sense to me is sleeping on
the street if like [ __ ] Taylor Swift
was there sure you were about you were
like her in a real yang I got it
intimate but no they were just as an
elephant and I walked past and this
group of ladies they were all all ladies
a group of ladies we're standing there
and they're like oh
Shane Gillis unlike a couple more
excited the one was just like gross and
gave me the finger really and I looked
back and I was like ah you don't mean
that
come on can you imagine being that let
me tell you right now if I saw bin Laden
and let's say I buy the idea that he
killed a few thousand people maybe did
maybe then what do I know what do I know
what do I know
eleven great if I saw bin lot like my
friend's parents were incinerated if I
saw bin Laden in a restaurant I would be
like that's bin Laden yeah you know it's
cliquey idea that people are that angry
at you yeah yeah what's he about it's
like if I saw a [ __ ] oj i'd be like
hi love i do co j i don't see him but
III I know where he hangs
I'd love oj I've said he's the only
motivational speaker that anyone should
follow because he's on a comeback he's
lived a full life you know what I didn't
even like oj simpson has really people
that hard on it all no you haven't
Heisman have you Heisman caught
someone's [ __ ] head off he capitated
his wife and and her [ __ ] boy got away
with it got away we walked went back to
jail somehow [ __ ] himself that way you
know yeah he is a guy and I eat what he
look he's the healthiest person on
Twitter most well-adjusted person he
gives advice he's golfing he's like
watch the drive like I always watch his
videos he looks good for his age he
seems happy
oh yeah I mean he's true